tu n'as pas de famille
tu n'as pas d'amis
tu as été maltraité jusqu'à ce que tu
t'en remets à moi
non tu as un but et il est énorme
je vais tout différemment cette fois
c'est ton agent de terrain fait ce qui
te semble le mieux il faut que je sois
sûr
quelle directive telle
reçue de neutraliser la cible
monsieur le Président nous avons une
crise en temps réel la mission avance on
est plus proche que jamais
prête à sortir des sentiers battus prête
à faire mon boulot madame
[Musique]
c'est ta couverture est grillée on ne
pourra pas te sauver il faudra que tu te
sauves toute seule opérer discrètement
et proprement soit extrêmement prudente
la cible ce sera toi
l'élément est en place l'opération est
lancée désormais on ne peut plus reculer
la sécurité inférieure le découdre ça
finira aux infos du soir
avez-vous atteint la cible tu vas
préparer à ça c'est notre mère à nous
faire le ménage
j'ai besoin que tu prennes conscience
des risques
j'ai conscience des risques